what do you get when you mix Ober with a
hospital Royal Pains Oh ball time
ah good dish good dish we have a athlete
that's collapsed what are you gonna do
check for a pulse call for help call for
help first thing you do call for help
[Music]
yes he pointed the personnel I need
those two gym bags right now if you want
some ice from those coolers move it does
he have a pulse all right we have to
break this little scene down athlete
collapses while playing basketball he
say he is not breathing it sounds like
he has no pulse at that point you call
help
911 one point somebody out because if
you just yell it hoping that someone
else will call 9-1-1 that may not happen
so point to someone say you call 9-1-1
and then right away chest compressions
chest compressions chest compressions
don't push with your arms push with your
upper body because then you could use
your weight to your advantage and not
tire as quickly then just by using your
arms when you're pushing do you want to
do it to the tune of stayin alive stayin
alive
uh alright that was bad singing but good
effort chest chest chest chest
compression sir why'd you off today dr.
Lawson I was status post cardiac arrest
got his pulse back and open his airway
did you really use gym bags for
immobilization yeah I can't wait to tell
him some sweaty boxers save his neck so
the thing with opening up his airway if
the patient is still basically in a coma
state they can't protect their airway
that's why we do the Glasgow Coma Scale
to see whether or not the person can
protect their airway and if they can't
they should be intubated because what
can happen is some secretions whether
it's alive a mucous vomit can get into
the mouth and then get aspirated into
the airway which will go into the lungs
and now we'll create a pneumonitis which
is a very serious condition which causes
Syria
inflammation of the lungs and can be
deadly Oh two-cent 80 BP 100 over 60
drop five of versed 150 of sux dr.
Lawson paramedics bringing in an 68 year
old with a STEMI waiting now 68 year-old
with the STEMI means an ST elevation mi
an ST elevation is something that we
look for on an EKG when someone's having
a heart attack and MI means myocardial
infarction just another name for a heart
attack into the femoral artery and
there's the blockage you can finish up
I'm gonna go out he's stable he just
needs an angio dr. wolf how's the kid
the EKG shows a third-degree AV block it
was unresponsive to meds I placed an
external pacer but I'm not getting
captured what's his BP hovering around
60 systolic all right he needs a wire
stat is Hank a cardiologist I'm so
confused what I'm interested in here is
this young athlete he said he has an AV
block which is a problem with the
electricity
within the heart that can cause the
heart to stop beating he's saying that
they're trying to create capture which
is when they put a device on the outside
of the chest that tries to capture the
hearts beat and reset it and give it the
proper rhythm now they're not having
success with that so he says I'm gonna
put in a wire essentially what he's
saying is he's gonna go from the
internal structures and control the
electricity of the heart that way now we
do this all the time for pacemakers and
defibrillators basically for all sorts
of congestive heart failure and
electrical anomalies of the heart
priority is mr. Gardner you'll see him
all the way through Gardner is stable
his BP is up as sad as 98% on two
leaders the ST segments are normalizing
in his pain is gone so how about today
we save two for the price of one let's
go I mean I totally agree with him here
why what does she want him to do babysit
the other VIP patient what good is that
gonna do them if he did the procedure he
opened up his arteries his ST segments
are normalizing which means that the EKG
is improving what else is she gonna do
[Music]
Wow still can't stop with the romance in
these medical shows with the making out
and the just medicine is fine we don't
need them just say let's go get that
long day of yours a happy ending it's
the dirty show I recognized mr.
Gardner's level of blockage I knew it
had to be relieved and I was confident
he would be successfully angioplasty
didn't survive
barring any bad luck well bad luck
rained and poured didn't it while you
had our senior CT surgeon in another
room to help me try to rescue a crashing
patient I made a judgment call you made
a mistake a fatal one and it's a shame
dr. Lawson because we all know you're
the most talented physician this
emergency department has seen and estar
was only on the rise was I know for the
average person that may watch this and
think oh that makes sense he got fired
to me it makes no sense at all I have no
idea what he did wrong it looked like he
completed most of the procedure and then
left the rest of it for another doctor
and then went to perform another
procedure he didn't go home to hang out
so I'm still flabbergasted as to why he
got fired but whatever it's clearly not
important for the show's storyline you
really need to get out of this apartment
and get some fresh air bro in Brooklyn
honestly it smells so bad it smells like
a moose had sex with a bucket of Chinese
food in here like musty and you kind of
look like Jesus and Patrick Dempsey had
a child and that child grew older and
then got really sick that's weird
look look look this trip is gonna get
you back on your feet I promise
trip what trip
to the Hamptons I've been telling you
about this all month yeah and all month
I've been saying no way a lot of
Medicine upfront a lot of no medicine in
the middle Blair
clear dr. silver here any damn kid's
gonna learn how to hold good drugs this
is concierge done some oxy well Crystal
group a few lines and chase it all down
with champagne having salad you kids
call it right what if it doesn't do
drugs why because she says she doesn't
lose flash pretty boy most drug addicts
are also liars sorry April if we gotta
get the stray into your system doctor
you may have missed a diagnosed oh
really who are you just a concerned
observer oh well I observe nausea
photosensitivity disorientation fewer
than telltale symptoms of an opioid
overdose what did you observe the same
symptoms that you are plus a couple
you're not like her my otic pupils and
Sledge toxidrome how you don't want to
understand he didn't even look at her
eyes how does he know what her pupils
look like I mean it sounds like he has
x-ray vision he could see from across
the room especially in a dark room how
is he able to see it not buying it Hank
alright let's go we go I got this from
here guy who are you I'm a lifeguard
are you board-certified in clinical
toxicology huh help me get her up
Baywatch I somehow doubt that this guy
is an interventional cardiologist
clinical toxicologist how many board
certifications does he have and they're
not even ones that go hand in hand like
if you're an ER doctor and you're
toxicologist I get it but being an
interventional cardiologist and a
toxicologist yeah those are nice
Ferraris
360 modena this isn't my blood
it's my girlfriend's um can you come
inside yeah yeah sure no malpractice
insurance know anything just oh yeah I'm
just gonna be casually your doctor I got
fainting she gonna bomb it he's sweating
oh that the seatbelt mark on his chest
could have a cardiac contusion which is
a bruise of the heart did you tell me
your oh did you factor aid supplies so
he has a bleeding disorder that if you
get into a car accident or any kind of
accident or for that matter you start
bleeding excessively
and you're missing one of the clotting
factors specifically factor eight that's
what he's talking about here I don't
know how he knows it's specifically
factor eight that's really impressive
and also how he knows exactly that he's
a hemophiliac it's very impressive
diagnostic skills that I feel are a
little bit past human abilities stay
with me down there you ever stay with me
Tucker stay with me Tucker stable
all right check you those up muffled
heart sounds animal pulses damn it
affects me thanks probably confused his
heart and bled into the pericardial so
what are you talking about look at his
heart is being squeezed and not
circulating blood to his brain he needs
the fluid drain but because of his
hemophilia I could kill him trying to
save him this is actually really similar
to what happened with the good doctors
pilot episode where the patient got into
also an accident and blood was pooling
around the heart we were worried about
cardiac tamponade where the heart's
trying to beat but it's there's a
buildup of fluid in the SAC surrounding
the heart so it has no room to beat
properly and therefore all the vital
organs are not getting enough blood
supply what complicates this case even
further and I have no idea again how he
knows he's a hemophiliac is that he's a
hemophiliac so if he's to do any kind of
procedure like insert a needle into the
pericardial sac and take the fluid away
so that the heart can beat properly you
can kill him because the he could bleed
out well I got so fake it's crazy
[Music]
okay good good
just take it easy pal just take it easy
take it easy I just cut open into your
heart and your ribs you're all good just
take it easy
he may be helped out big time
Libby helped up my man call 9-1-1 she
shows really funny I actually enjoyed
watching it as a regular show not just
as a medical drama there's obviously
some crazy unrealistic situations that
go on but the one part that is true is
VIP concierge doctors are all the rage
what Michael it was when I was in
medical school was to become a VIP
concierge doctor but for everybody make
it as a low-cost option and that's sort
of coming into existence with something
known as direct primary care and I'm
kind of excited about it click here for
my three favorite videos from the last
few months as always stay happy at home
[Music]